salut c'est la routine vous permettez
faites comme si je n'étais pas là
salut c'est la rupture à lui c'est la
superstition si tu arrêtes de trouver
donc il va revenir
salut c'est la déprime et je suis avec
une copine salué la paranoïa
là il ay bizarre un baiser débute au
salut c'est l'auto persuasion qui est
superbe il ne te mérite pas ça lui c'est
la colère aucune cuisine tout à faire
salut c'est la culpabilité
tu es vraiment qu'une merde
c'est la mélancolie
allez on se lavait
salut vous êtes qui des souvenirs ça tu
reviens décroche l'écran je devais
creuser crush crush décroche archi
décroche fallu et tape à coucher avec
quelqu'un pendant qu'on était séparé
on peut savoir qui c'est
alors
bah